okay you ready Jenna yep all
right we're going live we're live We
Live Jenna hi hi oh my goodness okay
everyone Welcome to our live stream this
is my sister Jenna hello I'm Justine we
are so excited for this because today we
are going to be showing you the brand
new pixel8 and the pixel8 pro and a huge
thank you to Google for sponsoring this
this is going to be so fun because this
is actually a shoppable YouTube video
live stream this is going to be so
awesome so let me show you guys a quick
little demo here look right now we have
the pixel 8 Pro I can quickly go over
here pin the pixel 8 in the Hazel and I
can also pin the Google pixel watch too
so basically if you see us looking over
here it's because we are monitoring the
chat as well so be sure you guys are you
know typing saying hello asking any
questions and like we said this is
shoppable so you are over there pinning
things you're basically doing everything
I'm just kind of here hanging out it was
so funny I was like do we need to get a
whole team to do this and I was like
wait it's all right here like we just
have this all at our fingertips which is
super exciting but the whole reason that
we're here is the brand new pixel phones
and we got a chance to go test them out
we've had them for what like a week week
and half it's about yeah a week or so
and like we said this is sponsored so
thank you so much to Google this is so
much fun but yeah we've been testing
this out we have had these devices which
uh our outfits today are the bay
inspired so I don't know if you guys can
notice or not these are the bay inspired
colors but yeah we've had so much fun
with the new pixel devices you know we
have the pixel 8 the pixel 8 Pro and
there are going to be some promos going
on so be sure to check the description
check you know Google the website and
and uh check out so yeah and I think the
most exciting part about this like as a
content creator is when these new
devices come out this gives us the
opportunity to really showcase the video
quality the picture quality I mean
there's so many new things in this and
what I love so much about Google is in
their entire like interface like they've
added so many new AI features oh yeah
and it's it's been so much fun we have a
bunch of demos to show you guys but also
so basically with both of these we have
new upgraded rear cameras we also have
the Google tensor G3 chip so this is
going to be the most powerful chip yet
so obviously with the cameras and the
editing and the AI we can do so much now
as much as I've been enjoying taking
pictures and videos I've actually found
myself enjoying editing and doing post
more than taking the pictures which is
kind of crazy cuz there's so many cool
features like you said we have some
demos coming uh do you do you have a
little video to play of our most recent
trip to San Diego where we were testing
these out I do so in this video you guys
will see some photo demos some video and
also the Cinematic blur for the video
which was actually still I think one of
my most favorite things so let's roll
that video and then when we come out of
that I'm going to be reading the chat
and then we'll have some more to talk
about what's new in the cameras so roll
the video Justine that's you that that's
[Music]
me
all right we're going to test out the 5x
Zoom here in video so right now we're 0.
five let's zoom in to
0.1
and5 and 20 look at that little birdie
up there I didn't even realize he was
there there until I zoomed
in
byebye all right let's take a 0.
five a
1x a
2X and a 5x now let's see how far we can
zoom in
digitally
30X so there is a 30X digital Zoom all
the way back back out it's
a05 there she
is taking the
photos we had so much fun taking photos
but one of the most fun things that I
had was using Magic Eraser with this you
can go in and basically remove anything
so I thought let's remove myself from
this Frame and all of my things from the
bench and it's like I was never even
there here's the before and here's the
after and when we zoom in it was like
she was never even there
[Music]
here's a front-facing camera test it's
so bright out oh my goodness but we're
here in
delmare and it is so
beautiful
so right now we're testing out the
Cinematic blur and this is pretty cool
because this gives you that Voca look
that we all like when you put on a lens
and you really open up the aperture but
here we can do this right on the Google
pixel8
pro here's a few portrait mode photos
that we took and these all turned out
really well and I was actually pretty
impressed with how well the bokeh turned
out and you can also adjust it and edit
and
post
oh my gosh um that was so much fun I I
just got sidetracked because I was
reading all of your uh comments over
here so hi Emily hi Kareem hello
everyone thanks so much again for
joining this live stream if you're just
joining us now this is sponsored by
Google and we're chatting about the
brand new pixel 8 and the pixel 8 Pro
phones and I really hope you joined to
see that video because that was great
great editing Justine thank you thank
you the video quality I was reading the
comments paper like the video quality
looks amazing and it really does and I
like how you said that you didn't even
realize that bird was there until you
did the five time zoom the five time
zoom is pretty awesome but first before
we get into the pixel8 pro let's start
with the pixel 8 let's talk about it so
yeah this here it is this has a 6.2 in
display it's actually 42% brighter than
the pixel 7s which is pretty bright like
I said we were out in the sun and we had
no trouble at all seeing this and it
does go from 60 to 120 Herz refresh rate
so if you're a gamer or you know an avid
scroller you can uh you know adjust
accordingly we do have three colors Rose
Hazel and obsidian and like I said this
does also have the 50 megapixel camera
and um yeah we have the Google tensor G3
chip and it's just great all these new
AI features great cameras good looking
it's like it is so nice oh oh you have
the matching one oh that is so I this
watch band with the pixel watch which
I'm going to pin here too this is the
pixel watch to um oh that is nice I I
can't can you guys see that it's kind of
far away but like you can see it looks
good I love this color it's a really
nice color it's pretty incredible pretty
great so that was the pixel 8s and the
the watch as well so now the pixel 8 Pro
I was so hyped to test this out because
this has the new 5x telephoto zoom and
we were talking about that in the video
when I zoomed in I had no idea that that
bird was even up there I didn't see it
at all with my eyes no didn't see it and
this comes in three different colors
this is the the bay color which we have
here the porcelain and obsidian which
color do you like the best well I mean I
already know you you know my favorite
color is blue yeah which color do you
like the best the blue okay looks so
good it does look really good and I just
like that it has the matte finish on the
back like that's really nice where this
has like more of like the shiny but I
mean they both look good depending on
what you want and like we said before
this is a very shoppable live stream so
you know get your credit card get your
fingers do some shopping Justine give us
a pin it's already pinned Jenna great
she's doing her job just just to make
sure but yeah this this has been so much
fun filming and um yeah we got great
colors we've got great upgrades should
we show them a demo of the magic editor
oh the magic editor yes now before
before we go into that everything that
we've been doing in testing is still
like pre-release software and I don't
know I I had you know lower expectations
but everything worked perfectly and it
was just so much fun and the magic
editor is where I feel like I was
thriving with my creativity well yeah
especially cuz you're you don't expect
these things to work as well as they do
and then with the magic editor we'll
just show you guys the demo but it's so
impressive how you really are able to
just remove people objects and things
from photos me as a graphic designer who
went to do you know how long ago it's
been since I was in college for for a
couple decades it's been a long time but
man I feel like one of those people that
are like I remember when I was your age
I had to Trek through the snow well we
have we used to have to I don't want to
talk about well I think about it because
it's like with this type of thing
normally we're putting it on our
computer we're opening up a third party
software and I'm spending hours to
remove and make it look like you know
that's wanted we don't do that anymore
we just go like this no watch this demo
R the demo Jenna made this demo so Props
to Jenna let's see if it's good first
here we
go magic editor is an experimental
editing experience that uses generative
AI it's really cool because you're able
to easily select a subject you can make
it larger you can make it smaller and
here you have the before and after of
this duck and another thing that you can
do is you can use it to easily remove
objects here I'm just circling this sign
and I'm able to erase it completely from
the photo and I'm not completely done
with my photo yet I'm also able to
resize myself if I want to make myself a
little bit larger in this photo of me
and my friend Sydney I can actually
easily just take Sydney out of the photo
if I want uh and here is a portrait
where you can adjust for different
portrait settings where here I decided
to give myself a little Sunset
Vibe sorry Sydney I took him out of the
photo hope he's is not watching so we
are we're back from Jenna's amazing demo
wasn't that cool I mean that was just
like the surface of what you can do like
it was literally just like a few things
the options are unlimited of what you
can do with you know your your pictures
and your videos and posts it's
remarkable now you took some night
photos as well using night shift and the
thing that I love about obviously like
these phones is how good they're getting
at night photos and taking night video
because that's one of the most difficult
things to do with these larger sensors
and these new cameras it's really giving
us that ability I mean there's times
where we're out trying to take a picture
when it's dark and we're literally using
another phone with the flashlight on to
take a picture of something but now you
know we have all these options like you
said you know we have night sight where
you're going to be able to take better
more vibrant more detailed pictures in
lower light situations so you don't need
to have you know two people holding a
flashlight to uh to make things brighter
no shall we hop into a little demo of
that let's do it okay here we go
night sight allows for more vibrant and
brighter photos and low light you can
select when you want to use this and
afterwards it will also tell you which
photos have been taken with night sight
overall you're going to get brighter
photos with so much more detail in lower
light scenarios here are some examples
of some night sight photos that I
took oh look at that one Jenna I know
right it's my favorite shot oh that's
nice get that get that Zoom
mhm where was this at Marina mhm
wow I like the enhance that really I
like the little demo there look at that
I love a nice little enhance look at
that fire good job good job thank you
well I didn't do it that was a that was
all Google I mean you did you took the
photo well I and I pushed the enhance
button push the button really really my
best word but yeah it it was actually
very impressive especially when you when
you zoom in um I feel like too with like
the AI like in post it kind of like
takes away like if there's any
graininess or things like that it's just
it's remarkable the things you can do
now just from your you know mobile
device now there's this other thing that
you guys may have seen these videos
floating around about best take this is
okay
so I like this we have another sister we
do uh Brienne hi Bri Bri she may she's
watching prob not she's probably working
but you can basically take a group photo
and then you can go in and choose to
change people's faces if they don't like
the way that they look if they didn't
smile if their eyes were closed changing
their expression
wild amount
ofing I think IED it's like well if you
did that's fine just choose another face
so with this best take I actually when I
saw that announcement I was like this is
really really cool I can't wait to try
that I mean I instantly thought of AR
sister because I mean I'm I've taken so
many photos like I don't even care
anymore I'm like well if I don't look
that great it's okay there's another one
that might be okay but Brienne is so
particular she's like okay well let's
take another one I'm like okay let's
just take a bunch and then she can pick
her face she's across the country right
now so we weren't able to demo this with
her but we will be seeing her soon yeah
actually very soon cuz we're going to be
flying back we can demo that with her
let's show you guys the demo I'm so
excited to show this to you guys okay
let's do best
take this is the best take demo this is
available on both the pixel 8 and the
pixel 8 Pro basically with this feature
if you are taking group shots with a
bunch of people chances are there's
going to be some shots where someone
doesn't like how they look so with this
feature you're actually able to select
the person you're able to change
different Expressions here is where I
blinked so I wanted to change it to
where I wasn't blinking and it's just a
really great feature to make sure that
everybody looks their
best I didn't have that many friends to
just Sydney again thanks Sydney Sydney
but for the future when you know there's
a big group of a big group of us hanging
out it it will be great everybody was so
busy this week so much so much new tech
you know it really is wild it's
definitely seon and thank you again to
Google for sponsoring this live stream
this was so fun when they were like hey
do you guys want to do a shoppable live
stream I was like yes yes we do this is
so cool and I love that I can seriously
just I can pin whatever I want like this
is I the power that I have the power of
pinning the power of pinning you're
unstoppable I want to know from you guys
in the comments has anybody been
shopping let us know if you are going to
be shopping what are you going to be
getting uh the pixel 8 Pro Bay oh
beautiful also look at this matchy Aruna
says Justine and Jenna together what a
treat can you believe it I know it is
pretty exciting it's pretty crazy right
what else we got going on um Patrick
wants to know what colors that we would
choose out of this lineup this is it
this is it this right here these are the
two they're so nice I know they are like
they're just great like the Hazel's got
like a nice
like I have you play I have played some
of my
memories that was nice that was a good
memory so we have a few other demos here
which one should we do next which was
your favorite all right let's see what
we got here oh well um jeez well as
we're talking about photos maybe we go
back into the Let's do let's do the
photo demo cuz like we said we have the
50 megapixel uh so the pictures now like
the quality it's just so crisp it's
vibrant the you can zoom in and see the
detail so let's uh let's talk about some
some Pro photos is this your your demo
here I don't know we'll see now with the
pixel 8 Pro we have an upgraded rear
camera system and the ability to take 50
megapixel high resolution photos with so
much more detail so here are just a few
examples of some of my favorite high
resolution photos as you can see there's
so much more detail they're vibrant and
you're able to zoom in and really see
that detail in these high resolution
photos there she is look at that you can
see the details in the reflection of my
sunnies wow I
know that was very impressive oh look at
that little duck yeah but wait until you
zoom in oh look at him I can see this
Duck's thoughts and soul look at that oh
my goodness isn't that crazy look at his
eyeball I know there's also macro mode
that allows to really get up close and
personal and get some really cool shots
there she is I got a little too close I
got a little pinch that's okay yeah but
with macro mode you I mean you know you
can get pretty close and look at like
look at that detail it's super detail
those are all like raw photos like I did
not do any editing none no editing at
all no there wasn't enough
time this is live stream but there still
was a lot of uh preparation that went
into it which not complaining it's been
honestly so much fun this has been such
a fun new way of like curating content
yeah cuz normally when we put together a
review it's like we have to well we do
have to Super plan it so but this like
we can say whatever we want and it's
live but we also have these little demos
for you which is really fun so I'd love
to hear what you guys think about this
it's pretty great it is so Lou says that
they love and enjoy our videos much love
and support thank you how do you feel
about these live streams though right
pretty fun it's pretty cool
um let's see we've got oh yes I you
don't even have to say it are you going
to talk about the
thermometer yes I knew it I for so we
once went and visited it was at the
world's largest thermometer and for
whatever reason like I always have
trouble spelling thermometer but when I
saw the thermometer text super huge I
was like at the gift shop yeah I was
like thermometer thermometer thermometer
that's that makes it so much easier for
me to spell it so now built in to the
thermometer pixel 8 Pro is a thermometer
it's cool because there's a sensor in
the back and you can use it to do the
temperature of different objects uh we
do have a a quick little demo if you
want to if you want to roll that but
it's so fun I mean you never know when
you need to know the temperature of a
surface yeah and this isn't something
that you're going to be using to like
tell temperatures of food or like people
like this is like objects you could do
food I did a beverage a drink so it's
like if I want to know you know is my
coffee too pot maybe but like if you're
using it to tell the temperature of like
the internal of meat if you're cooking
it like an internal meat
thermometer no I thought you meant like
a popsicle no no no no I was thinking
the cool side of things yeah I was like
don't use this for cooking I mean oh my
gosh absolutely not but if you want to
know your Popsicle or your drink for it
so let's show this demo of Jenna using
the thermometer thermometer thermometer
okay here we go Jen pixel 8 Pro now has
a ther ometer thanks to its temperature
sensor on the back you can choose which
subject you'd like to use this on or you
can just let it work on the default
setting I like the default setting it's
pretty great it was crazy too cuz it was
like I did that within like a minute of
each other and then when I took the
temperature again my drink went up 2°
cuz it was so hot that week and it was
so hot inside my home I was testing it
out while I was like editing videos and
then I was like okay so the temperature
of of like my computer just not doing
anything and then you know putting a
little bit of a you know workload on it
I was like okay you can see it jumping
up a little which is co it gets pretty
warm oh do we have a
notification where did that come from we
have so many pieces of te on it wants me
to
move oh my reminder to move thank you so
much um I actually need that reminder
I'm not going to do that right now but
here move your arms a little bit for
some reason I get very very distracted
did so when I'm reading something I will
jump do a million different things so I
thought it was really cool to do the
read aloud which was really cool you can
basically have the Google Assistant read
you anything on Chrome like read you a
website so I have a little demo of that
that's cool and again thank you to
Google for sponsoring this video again
this video is shoppable so as you can
see these little products keep popping
up and I am pinning those so let's roll
into Jenna's little grammar test shall
we
so that was actually a demo of the you
you hit the wrong video did I hit the
wrong one that's okay that was that was
an AI demo for when it comes to texting
so I'm really I'm a sloppy text wait
should we go back to then you can
explain what's happening let's go back
let's go back okay I messed up I clicked
the wrong button it's okay click click
the read aloud so we'll do the read
aloud demo well why don't we just talk
about what we just you just showed us
okay so that was yeah so with you know
one of the new AI features like I said
like there's all types of things that
are kind of going to make your life
easier so when I'm texting I'm a really
sloppy texter and sometimes the words
just don't come out the way that you
know they're supposed to but there's now
like the quick little AI fix where it
will you know take into consideration
what you're saying and it will make it
more uh grammatically correct as you
will and it will use AI to kind of
assume what you're wanting to say and
there's obviously different things that
you could pick if it wasn't right the
first time but every time I was using it
it was it was very accurate and it was
making me um not have as many spelling
erors which uh you know you love to see
that's a really cool feature okay so now
we're going to go to the one that I was
supposed to click that's okay all right
here we go I'm not going to mess it up
this
time hey
Google read
aloud from
space.com annular solar eclipse 2023
live updates by Brett Tingley Daisy
dovic on October 14th 2023 an annular
solar eclipse will be visible from much
of the southwestern United States in
Central
America did you know did you the solar
eclipse is happening in a couple days I
actually did only because when I I went
to the store they were selling a bunch
of um what are they the eye protectors
the glasses I remember the one time I
took you to the dentist and the eclipse
was happening I got and I got out I was
all like loopy and and I was like oh
look at this don't look at it don't look
at it oh my gosh okay so um there's also
another feature that isn't necessarily
just for the pixel phones but it was
something that was really cool
especially since we have um you know we
have the you know the new chip and it's
just so powerful so this demonstration
was really cool because we both travel a
lot you know and we both are always I
feel like looking for cool places to
film or to shoot photography or things
like that so this was an immersive view
that is in Google maps and it can kind
of like it's what it sounds you it's an
immersive view of what's around you so
this is something that was really cool
so please please Ru the demo Justine
okay this is actually really cool like
like you said for filming yeah U let's
show you guys this and then we can chat
about it it shows you the vibe we like
to know the vibe before we we go
places now this next feature is through
Google Maps and it's called immersive
view this isn't new but trying it out on
the pixel devices was actually pretty
fun it was running so well this
basically uses AI to let you explore
things that you want to explore so here
I typed in the Eiffel Tower it kind of
just gives you a better understanding of
things around it you can kind of get the
vibe and if you're going to be traveling
somewhere I feel like this is a really
great feature for you to see what's
around you I'm always looking for places
to go when I'm trying to get like a cool
shot here's where I was testing it out
with the Golden Gate Bridge and what's
actually really neat as well is you can
adjust the time and weather so if you're
looking to go around Sunset you can kind
of get a Vibe of what it's going to be
like so this was just a fun feature uh
and especially fun testing it out on the
allnew pixel
8 doesn't that look incredible it looks
so cool it and it's running so smooth
obviously because we have the most
powerful chip yet on the pixels and it
was just it was really really cool I was
like I feel like I'm there but and being
able to adjust for like the weather and
the time of day uh it can I feel like
give you a better sense of what to
expect so definitely we'll be using that
when we're going to be traveling to
places where we need to kind of you know
scope something up for maybe filming
have you been to Paris before no have
you yeah when oh it's been a long time
without me without you that feels it
felt very wrong yes um yeah it's
actually pretty cool it's it's weird
because it's like you do see these
things and then like you really get to
go experience it in real life but
sometimes there's places that you really
can't go so to be able to do that
virtually is is pretty awesome
interesting yeah I have not been there
but yeah that feature was just it was
something I was like oh this is cool I
didn't know it existed and I definitely
will be using it um some people were
asking about the battery
life um impressive serious I know like
the other day I didn't even charge it at
night and then I got up and like I
thought I had charged it and then I was
still using it like almost the entire
day same here I was actually very very
surprised I was like oh I need to charge
this and I was like oh I still have a
lot of battery so um I charged it
obviously then before the live stream
but yeah I was very impressed with the
battery life yeah and I mean that for me
also is like super well for pretty much
everyone because it's basically how you
get through your day it is and
especially with us like we are such
power users CU it's you know our hobby
our job our life it's kind of everything
so we are always on our devices and yeah
definitely needed to have a a good
battery and the battery life definitely
did not disappoint me I just want to
make sure did we go through all of our
demos let me see I think we did cuz we
there was so much more that we wanted to
show you and we're like we only have
like a 30 minute time slot to do all of
this stuff I'm pretty sure we did I had
some other demos that I was doing where
I was just kind of showing like just the
editing and you know like just me
editing the photos and stuff which it
was really really wait we did not go
through we forgot one is it do you see
it or did I not put it in you have not
put it in and it was such a good one so
this was the demo of the audio uh the
audio erase did you just send it to me
no you didn't send it to me I did send
it to you before it was the audio erase
in video so this was huge because we
obviously film a lot of video that's our
life and oh this is such a good demo
just well okay you can post it after
this okay you're right I you guys can
check that out on uh youtube.com/ Jer
but anyway so this is this is a feature
where once again it uses Ai and uh what
it does is it takes into consideration
all of the noise that's happening in the
background so the video that I did a
demo of was it was me at the marina
filming a sailboat and I was like
talking to Sydney and I was like oh
actually you know what I don't want us
to be talking in the background I also
want to take out some wind noise so what
I did was I was able to with the new You
Know audio eraser it uses Ai and it
senses you know what's not supposed to
be there so I was able to turn the wind
down so that I was able to obviously not
make the wind as loud I turned turned
speech down 100% so that it got rid of
the you know Sydney and I talking in the
background and I just had a nice
peaceful video of a sailboat with no
distracting sound and I'm trying to find
it what do you remember what you called
it was it one of the first ones that you
sent me it probably has the word audio
in it maybe I didn't upload it cuz I
wait voice erase demo voice erase is
that it demo it could be voice erase cuz
I did erase is that what you did let's
see let's see okay hold on a second I'm
still working on this this is this is a
process this is live people this is our
live stream once again thank you to
Google for uh for sponsoring this live
it's happening live you could be posting
anything right now I'm scared I feel
like I I shouldn't do it cuz I haven't
put it in no it's probably fine oh Jenna
I'm nervous I don't want to do it too
many things can go wrong push the button
just I don't want to push the button I'm
scared I'm scared push the button just
I'm not doing it I'm not doing it man
the pitting princess over here she will
not push the button I got so nervous cuz
I was like I think that was the video
but I was afraid so post it on your
Twitter after be posting it so be sure
to check it out because that was a very
that was actually the one thing that I
was also super impressed with because
you hate when there's like distracting
sounds in the background and now you
don't have to take this to your laptop
you can just do it on your phone and why
this is also so cool it's like I feel
like we're getting so accustomed to
being able to remove things from photos
so now being able to take that a whole
step further and remove things from
audio which I sometimes feel like audio
is one of the most important parts of
these content pieces is because you want
to be able to hear your subject clearly
and all of that stuff so super important
that I remember you always saying like
audio is the most important you're like
audio and lighting so I feel like that
feature too like like you said you don't
want to hear all these distracting
sounds in the background especially you
know if people are just talking about
nothing which we were in the demo
they're all telling me to push the
button I'm not I can't I just push the
button well the framing wasn't right
it's just I don't I don't know I'm sorry
I just it's live on the edge push the
button oh my gosh that way to push the
button so bad I can't you guys will just
have to uh just have to see see my demo
we are coming to the end of our live
stream but is there anything else you
want to add I mean this was honestly so
much fun I really really enjoyed kind of
this new way of reviewing these phones
this was pretty fun it was actually
really cool it it's fun because it's
like I mean yeah like you said it's new
it's exciting it's shoppable and we is
there anything we' like more than
shopping maybe sleeping I really do
enjoy sleeping s speaking of sleep TR
the new too this is such a this feels so
light on my wrist honestly is a nice
look I really like it a lot like it's
really pretty it's super light so light
it's Sleek you guys can shop it today
you can't shop it and I know there are
going to be some promotions going on
that started uh early October going into
the 16th so be sure to check out all
those promotions and thank you so much
to Google for this this was and thank
you for having me on your channel yes
thank you so much for joining me cuz at
any time I would have enjoyed doing it
alone but it's wa no but it's much more
enjoyable having you here wow you would
have had any demos you have
that's true no demos Jenna thank you for
your great demos though yeah you're
welcome you guys can see the the one
since she didn't push the button I I
couldn't push the button I was too
scared that's okay I don't you never
know so anyway if you guys want to shop
this video here's the pixel 8 Pro and
then I'm going to pin the Hazel pixel 8
and of course our pixel watch and that's
it for us I can't wait to go back and
watch this I know I'm excited it's going
to be so much fun but yeah thank you so
much again to Google for sponsoring the
stream thank you so much for having me
uh hope you guys have a great rest of
your day do some shopping and uh yeah
we'll see you maybe again for another
live stream you never know this was so
much fun all right thank you guys for
watching and now I have some very
important disclaimers from Google again
thank you guys so much for watching and
thank you to Google for sponsoring this
video Happy shopping bye okay hold on
here we go here we go roll the end
[Music]
screen
w